chuckle I have three little girls and
I'm really intrigued by Brazilian
Jujitsu what form of martial art would
you put your kids in yeah put your kids
into jiu-jitsu do it immediately we kind
of covered this the last podcast and
that is the fact that if you got to
teach your kids look don't get in a
street fight don't get into a fight in
the playground if someone wants to fight
you run away and that's what they should
do and you know later when they start to
become mature enough to make real
decisions that should guide them and
occasionally as a man you may have to
stand your ground and fight and that's
understandable right but as a little kid
who might be getting picked on by bigger
kids
hey Oh somebody gets in your face run
away if you really think you're gonna
get hurt run away so you have that self
defense mechanism already what you don't
have and what you are not born with is
when that bully grabs you and pulls you
to the ground or grabs you and holds on
to you and won't let you leave that is
when you need to know how to grapple and
Jiu Jitsu is what teaches you how to
grapple so eventually like you just said
you do want your kids to spar a little
bit you do want your kids to know how to
throw some good combinations Yeah right
I mean they should know how to do that
you know actually the other night I was
working with Dean and we were working
with a couple people and just go he was
going over some basic self-defense and
there are some legit basic self-defense
moves that people should know
we know someone bear-hugs you someone
had box you now we don't think about
them at the high level of jujitsu
because we we welcome someone head
locking us we welcome that stuff because
we're so used to it it says we have an
advantage when we get there but to a kid
you get thrown into a headlock a first
Street fight I ever got the first guy
can't call it a street fight the first
time I ever got into a fight wasn't you
know like fourth or fifth grade and this
kid who was definitely way stronger than
me grabbed me in a headlock was holding
me on the ground and punched me in the
head and I did couldn't do anything and
you know it got broken up ass
20 seconds by the principal but those
okay you know okay that that wasn't cool
so what you want your kid cuz if that
kid would have tried to attack me when I
was standing up I could just run away
from him
but once he grabbed ahold of me and all
of a sudden I can't do anything so
that's why jujitsu is the first thing
you want to learn it's also as I said
last and it's the most technical thing
it there's the most to learn it's a
never-ending knowledge quest so you want
to get on that quest as early as
possible now on top of that and what's
really good about jujitsu and again this
is something that I've talked about
before but when you talk about
traditional martial arts and you imagine
you know a traditional martial arts dojo
where people in plain white keys are
standing in a very clean and Spartan
facility with samurai swords hanging on
the wall and they're bowing to the
sensei that implies a certain amount of
knowledge will be passed and a certain
amount of etiquette
will be passed and the etiquette and the
knowledge that we passed will be
toughness and confidence and humility
and as a matter of fact if you go to a
traditional martial arts school and you
bring your kid in there and you say I
want my kid to train what will he get
out of it one of the things they're
gonna say is he's gonna learn to be
confident or she's gonna learn humility
and they will teach them that verbally
it will be a lesson it will be a book
almost a book lesson on this is humility
and this is confidence and hold your
head high Jiu Jitsu teaches those things
not theoretically but for real because
in jiu-jitsu you will get humbled you
will get humbled by up for someone
that's smaller than you by someone
that's weaker than you they will submit
you they
hold you down and you won't be able to
do anything about it and that is
humility and that is where you learn
humility and jujitsu and same thing with
confidence you know you will learn as
you get better at Jiu Jitsu that hey I
know something and I know I can handle
myself in bad situations so it truly
teaches humility and confidence not
theoretically but in a very practical
sense you know
so get your kids down to the Jiu Jitsu
school get him enrolled and you know we
did what we did a podcast where we
talked about how to find a good Jiu
Jitsu school so find a good reputable
place and get your kids down there and
you know what when you bring your kids
in to start jujitsu get your dang self
on the mat too because you got to know
it and it's everybody should know ya
then except for bullies and evil people
they should be banned from jiu-jitsu
because it's too powerful a good another
element that that you might not think of
right off the bat but the fact that
you'll meet friends because jiu-jitsu
for whatever reason I mean it just might
be the culture in general but when you
go to like the Jiu Jitsu mats you go on
the mats it's not like how you're saying
like a traditional martial arts school
where you're like don't talk bow be
rigid stand like this while this sensei
is talking say yes or no sir it's it's
really I mean in my experience that I've
been to a lot especially here in
Southern California there that's where
most of them are it's real even though
the more rigid ones are casual before
class you can talk even during class as
long as you're not talking while the
instructors yeah do you do that in the
school you wouldn't do that anywhere
yeah exactly you know but you know
you're practicing moves it's it's of
course you don't want to deviate too
much from the lesson but it's just more
social and so you talk after class and
you'll find that that the atmosphere is
really conducive to gravitating towards
people that that have the same interests
of you even outside of jiu-jitsu and
kids especially men because you know the
teachers are way more lenient with
kids when they're running around and you
know you telling them go do this move
and they might be talking a little bit
about something or whatever if they're
having fun which it is very fun um
they're just gonna want to do it some
more
my daughter's too and we found a place
that that could facilitate a
two-year-old situation and she would
always look forward to it cuz they she
just think it's just one big just play
house the broth housing the whole time
it's the ultimate dream for a kid yeah a
room with padded floors and padded walls
yeah you can grab the clothes rough
house all you want people to the ground
yeah you're not gonna get punched or
kicked or you know yeah it's yeah so
there is a a good community aspect to
jiu-jitsu yes very much so which echo
likes very much so